Hello I'm Luis Bettenncourt. I'm the
director of the Global Sustainability
Summer School here at the Santa Fe
Institute. Today we're kicking off the
school. It will be two weeks which
students or lecturers will spend
together trying to bring together in the
same place some of the state of the art in
thinking and in technology for how
cities are becoming more sustainable.
Relative to previous schools we have a
much bigger emphasis on people, on
institutions, on new technologies that
are kind of bridging the human
experience with issues of the
environment: like mapping and evaluating
solar and wind potential of built spaces
and community organizations. And we are
also looking at many different places
and already at this stage many of their
implementation plans from Los Angeles to
Chicago to Santa Fe, from India to parts
of Asia and Africa.
it's an exciting world where we're seeing
change. We're seeing its complexity and
we're creating the knowledge that we
hope will make a difference in the
decades to come.